near long Binh damages assessed at the
third ordnance ammunition depot in the
grim aftermath of a DC Knight attack an
ammunition pad with 6000 howitzer shells
was detonated during the attack gouging
out a crater nearly 200 feet across and
almost 30 feet deep the huge fireball
from the blast was visible in Saigon 22
kilometers away where buildings were
shaken and windows broken such was its
force that a quarter mile away this
truck loaded with shells was flipped
over like a toy the mammoth blast set
off secondary explosions and fires at
other ammunition pads but although
thousands of shells were burned there
were no other major detonation the
attack in which two men were killed and
nine wounded began when a patrol in the
depot was hit by rifle fire it was not
determined if the big explosion was
caused by a mortar shell or a time bomb
but the following day a true TNT satchel
charge was recovered from another
ammunition pad its wristwatch timing
mechanism had failed only 50 minutes
before detonation
with the shattering explosion still
fresh in their minds salvage crews begin
recovery and removal of scores of
scattered shells and broken crates the
first step toward bringing the hard-hit
Depot back to normal
on 3 November US Army commander William
C Westmoreland arrives at Benoit to
present a distinguished Unit Citation to
the 1st battalion 503rd Infantry of the
173rd Airborne Brigade the unit is being
honored for its extraordinary heroism
during an engagement in November of 1965
after trooping the line general
Westmoreland and Major General Paul
Smith commander of the 173rd mount the
reviewing stand to hear the Presidential
Citation read it states in part despite
the constant Vietcong assaults their
continued attack in human waves and the
many casualties sustained by the
American unit the gallant and determined
troops of the 1st battalion 503rd
infantry repulsed the Vietcong and
inflicted severe losses on them after
the reading an honor guard brings the
unit's flag forward as general
Westmoreland steps down to a fix the
distinguished Unit Citation streamers
this is the second such citation for the
unit which earned its first on
Corregidor during World War two
returning to the stand
general Westmoreland addresses the men
Joe Smith
proudly officers and troopers of the
first Battalion five old third Airborne
Infantry I have just had the great
pleasure of pinning on your colors a
streamer signifying that you have earned
the distinction of the award of the
Presidential Unit Citation this is the
highest unit award that a unit of the
Armed Forces of the United States can
receive it is my privilege in behalf of
the president United States to make this
presentation today I congratulate you on
your past performance and will continue
to expect great things of this
distinguished organization a one hundred
and seventy third Airborne Brigade in
the future
then to the strains of a stirring March
the men of the heroic battalion proudly
pass and review at not wrong units from
the Vietnamese and United States Army
and the Vietnamese Navy gather in
celebration of national Independence Day
November 1st amidst a large crowd of
onlookers the troops stand at attention
and salute as an honor guard raises the
Vietnamese flag symbol of the Second
Republic founded three years ago the
Kahn hua province chief an airborne
troop commander is on hand to deliver an
address expressing the nation's
gratitude for United States aid in the
struggle to maintain independence then
distinguished individuals from both
American and Vietnamese units come
forward to receive decorations a
high-ranking officer receives the
Vietnamese Medal of Honor second-class
from the province chief as does Master
Sergeant Donald's shirts a Mac V
intelligence advisors members of a
distinguished paratrooper unit are also
awarded similar honors
then the men reassembled to pass in
review
climaxing several days of National Day
celebrations in the area on the
northwest coast of Taiwan Generalissimo
Chiang kai-shek and a host of
dignitaries including members of the US
military advisory assistance group
prepared to observe exercise nan Chang a
combined sea air and land operation the
exercise is the Republic of China's
annual Armed Forces demonstration held
on the 19th of October this year's
program demonstrates nationalist China's
military invasion capability
well-drilled infantry advance in land
supported by a massive artillery
bombardment from the beachhead machine
guns and flamethrowers hip mock defense
position in the frontal attack
concrete tank traps are used for cover
by the advancing forces as a naval
bombardment supports the invasion
demonstration concludes as crack
airborne units cascade behind the
secondary defense observers agree that
the 600,000 some-odd military force of
Chiang kai-shek's command is in a high
state of preparedness due to constant
training I am certain first class john
ii garrison enlisted operations advisor
assigned to the northern advisory team
training advisor division army section
mag in the background you have the
entrance to the first NCO Academy a
portion of the Chinese first field army
unlike NCO schools as we know them the
primary mission of this school is to
give the students a high school
education at the same time preparing
them for a military career as
noncommissioned officer at the
successful completion of the course the
students are given a rank of Corporal
and must serve six years on
active duty the school under his present
concept were started in May of 1965 at
that time fund from the military
assistance program were used for
construction of the building however
since that time the Chinese army has
taken over the maintenance and
construction of new facilities there are
no US advisors assigned permanently to
the school however the advisors of the
northern advisory team are always
available to offer assistance or advice
when needed academic curriculum for the
NCO candidates is similar to that taught
in u.s. high school algebra and geometry
prepare the student for difficult
technical training which lies ahead to
better understand their American
military advisers the trainees learn to
read write and speak English I know what
I'm puzzled I don't have to spit up on
attachment far to bed in the field of
Sciences basic chemistry gives the
student a fundamental background in the
use of chemicals as they conduct
classroom experiments through his
biology studies the NCO candidate gains
an understanding of the bodily processes
of man and the effect of germs upon
living cells here at Jung Lee particular
stress is given to physical fitness the
wave drill limbers up legs and torsos
fundamentally a Military Academy the
school teaches a full schedule of
military courses including sand table
tactics weaponry classes provide
instruction on such automatic weapons as
the machine gun both 30 and 50 caliber
arms used by the nationalist Chinese or
of us manufacture and American army
advisors direct maintenance the standard
US Army 45 is also the handgun issued to
these NCO trainees many are expert shots
motor drills turn out highly proficient
teams with a clear understanding of the
weapons use that nearby chun-yan is the
Republic of China armored center and
school operated by the Chinese 1st
Armored Division the center offers
complex courses covering the entire
spectrum of the Army's armored vehicles
and their communications network in a
class devoted to the study of
communications equipment armor students
learn how to operate and perform simple
maintenance on several models of
american-made military radios third of
all student research is the armor
academy library technical books manuals
and pamphlets printed in both chinese
and english are to be found here
constantly growing the library poses a
problem a new wing has recently been
added and still more shelf space is
required practical application of
classroom training is the next step as
eager students are permitted to begin
maintenance procedures on armored
vehicles and engines of World War two
vintage tanks and other vehicles are
supplied by the United States Army
elsewhere at the school's fire Direction
center trainees learn to plot fire
missions for such artillery weapons as
the 105 millimeter howitzer mounted on a
world war ii m7 chassis however it is in
new condition
in final stages of training new tank men
are put through their paces with their
m41 tanks during firing exercises to the
observer it is clear the u.s. commitment
in army advisors and materiel has not
been wasted today the military posture
of the Republic of China is a major
factor in the affairs of Southeast Asia
a tool along Korn University in Bangkok
Thailand president lyndon b johnson is
welcomed enthusiastically on 29 october
the second day of a three-day visit to
that nation the president enters the
university auditorium and dawns academic
robes to receive an honorary degree of
Doctor of political science with King
Bhumibol Auto higher debt among those
present my nation today is bearing a
heavy load in the Vietnamese conflict
alongside of your nation the central
tragedy of our times is the human and
material waste that goes into war it is
my hope and my firm expectation that as
soon as Hanoi accept reality and the war
in Vietnam ends it will be possible to
devote substantially greater funds to
the relief of all human need in the
world to the enrichment of life and in
that larger effort we believe that
Southeast Asia will have its full share
because we know that you believe as we
do that we had much prefer to take our
material resources and put them in bread
did for babies and to put them in
bullets and bombs on 30 October at Don
Milani Airport flower girls threw petals
in the path of the first u.s. president
to visit Thailand and his first lady as
they bid farewell to their host the
Royal Thai Air Force Band plays as US
Air Force One glistening in the early
morning sunlight takes off for Kuala
Lumpur Malaysia
one hour and 32 minutes later Air Force
One touches down at Kuala Lumpur's
International Airport the Malaysians
extend an elaborate welcome to the first
United States President to visit their
nation and to mrs. Johnson among the
dignitaries on hand to greet them are
Malaysia's king and queen an honor guard
stands by as the king escorts President
Johnson to the dais followed by the
Queen and first lady the 101 man honor
guard is from the Royal Mail a regiment
the United States chief executive
responds to the warm welcome given to
him upon his arrival you valiantly
subdued a communist insurgency in your
own nation and then from the very same
room where you want planned battle
strategy you plan the works of peace you
begin building a free and prosperous
countryside that can relieve the poverty
and the apathy upon which communism so
often thrives your achievement in this
respect I believe has the greatest
significance for our struggle in Vietnam
today you have shown that military
action can stop communist aggression and
that while the aggression is being
stopped and even more strongly when it
is stopped the peace as well as the war
can be won your example offers us hope
for the future it is a great pleasure to
be here and to see firsthand and miss
Johnson and I look forward with great
pleasure to our state with you thank you
very much that night a glittering state
banquet is held at Parliament House in
honor of the president one highlight is
the colorful Malaysian ballet
performance
in his final speech before flying to
South Korea the president makes his
first direct comment on the latest
Chinese nuclear test I have been in Asia
the Communist Chinese have exploded
another nuclear weapon which they state
was attached to a missile the pursuit of
a national nuclear capability not only
makes international arms control
including a nuclear test ban and a
non-proliferation treaty vastly more
difficulty it also invites danger to
China itself for the leaders of China
must realize that any nuclear capability
they can develop can and will be
deterred we have already declared that
nations which do not seek national
nuclear weapons can be sure that they
will have our strong support if they
need it against any threat of any
nuclear blackmail
activities of a u.s. mobile training
team within Bolivia are varied and wide
the mission of the three-man team from
eighth Special Forces Group airborne
stationed at Fort Gulick Canal Zone is
to give general training to male and
female nurses working at the Bolivian
military hospital in La Paz the team
supervises a six-week training course
including both classroom and practical
work in the hospital the director and
captain joseph marr paused for a look at
some of the outpatient captain Mar and
his team are honored in a formal
ceremony held on the grounds of the
hospital the occasion is attended by
Bolivian and American notables along
with hospital personnel it reflects a
measure of the appreciation and
wholehearted cooperation on the part of
the Bolivian government as expressed by
the Bolivian Minister of Defense at the
school of the Army in Cochabamba another
mobile training team under Maj Patsy a
millon Tony teaches a course in
counterinsurgency the 26 students all
graduates of the Bolivian General Staff
School welcome the course in interior
defense and development as they prefer
to call it although members of the team
conduct most of the instruction guest
speakers are frequently included in the
program enrollment is limited to only
the most deserving career officers at
graduation ceremonies major Millan Tony
delivers an address to the class and
attending notables which include general
Guzman the Minister of National Defense
and Colonel Kenneth Masek chief of the
US Army mission to Bolivia major Millan
Tony then presents diplomas to the
graduates concrete evidence of the
excellent rapport established between
the mobile training team and students
with a common goal
santa cruz is the setting for another
activity of the mobile training team the
hog project has been built under the
supervision of MTT on hand for the
dedication our officers from the US Army
mission and officials from the Agency
for International Development along with
members of the MTT a commemorating
plaque is unveiled by Colonel Lawrence
Horace chief military group following
the dedication the officials take a tour
of the farm the project started in April
1965 will provide more than 1,000 fat
hogs per year yet another activity of
MTT is an interest in Bolivia's boys
town located near la paz on one of the
frequent visits team leader captain mar
a company's major CA was Kowski medical
advisor of the u.s. army mission to
bolivia these boys are waiting for
medical treatment
captain Maher is present on his off-duty
time to learn and to offer any
assistance possible scrapes and cut
fingers are common among active
youngsters and it doesn't hurt a bit
Maj wis Kowski does the honors in
distributing bars of soap to the boys
they're brief but very welcome visit
concluded Maj wish Kowski and Captain
Mart ake their leave adios amigos come
again soon
you